laut und herzlich willkommen hallo
lieber gerade mein ich bin mit meinem
grundstück upper dir hast ein schild
abgebaut neckar hier das ist mein
grundstück um kräfte zu schlagen hier
das projekt komme ich hab sogar schon
reisen schwer also nie freunde wir
befinden uns hier in einem neuen projekt
auf einem kanal und zwar minecraft leben
viele hatten es sich gewünscht und ich
hatte dann jetzt bin ich hier
amg hat gerade bumsti geschrieben vor
bistum hat ein starterpaket für jeden
neuling
das ist okay wir sind ja gerade du wirst
jetzt ein bissl ein wunderschönes
grundstück hierbei anspruch das ist vor
diesem monument wasser 4e anbaut hinter
uns das riesen dingen das ist wie gesagt
so firenze nicht kirche das geschäft
segel so ein bisschen tatsächlich hast
du aber auch eine kirche direkt neben
die uns war diese stein denkt ihr dass
nämlich die armee lohkirchen dann kannst
du da reingehen awd
befällt nicht gedacht ich bin
unglaublich froh hier nicht gut das ist
nämlich der baum des lebens der von dem
komplett geisteskranken gebaut wird und
wie immer noch gespannt ob das
irgendwann auf die kette kriegt
alesina serie sich schon auf das ist
richtig sie kein von uralter was er an
holz man darf halt nur so im mittelalter
stil dollar bzw
sollte es ja genau also so
mittelalterlich fantasy welche so ruhig
ist es glaube ich insgesamt gehalten
also moore ja zum beispiel auch so
fliegen inseln und sowas in der richtung
wanfried kopf hat sich deine augen wenn
du es nicht wenn ihr mich nicht ziehen
und macht mal das monster wider der
wollen wir ein starterpaket geben mit
dem song sogar ordentlich wert übrigens
ab und zu mal den den shader wechseln
einfach weil bei nacht das eine besser
aus damit er das andere und so und das
tolle bei diesem projekt ist ich darf
hier soviel stream wie ich möchte nicht
darf soviel offline scream spielen wie
ich möchte
das heißt es kann sein dass im zweiten
paar schon mein haus seht und dann
gleich noch nicht ausgebaut habe als ich
mal irgendwie langeweile haben du kannst
ja zum beispiel aufzeichnen lassen einen
vertrag bei deutschen konsums geh ja und
ich bin übrigens auch dass ich schon mal
gedacht
twitch partner
den kennst du schön dass die regenzeit
vom neuen zeit geht's direkt welche zum
blutet das tippen
hiervon vermuten ich muss ja schön des
ätna ist es etwas steiler darf nicht
egal ob keinen auf keinen fall nehmen
töten wollte ich vergesse ich mache
diesen
das ist der sieg fährt aus
als solche aber ich finde es blöd das
ist alles so leuchtet dann die ganzen
müssten von leuten ich kann noch mal den
schicken nämlich sonst war sehr sehr
schnell da die ich hier habe ich denke
bei nacht ist zum beispiel der jetzt
grad ganz gut also ja jeweils zustrom
waffe genau wenn du mal was verzaubern
will sie es direkt so ein öffentlicher
verzauberung tasten weniger bedürfnis
abgabe einfach zu dir und du kannst auch
natürlich da reingehen können stress
genommen dass ich könnt ihr hier finden
könnt ihr umgehen auch wenn du magst
sondern hier sind auch noch so offen mir
zu den anfang oder crafting table
schmiedel
so wie du möchtest kannst du gerne alles
mitbenutzen okay du hast sogar ein
brunnen gebaut also ich weiß nicht ob
ich das geht alles schön machen werde
ja natürlich das aber als zeit dass dein
leben leben in den entscheiden konnte
kommende longines titeln genehmer was
euch dennoch sagen was wichtiges
daume stellen simon thomas
er wurde aus lasst es ist simon dahinter
der große turm mit dem roten meer ziehen
ist von glp das wasser gesprungen
das ist sehr intelligent gewesen ich
kann hier wieder hoch ich möchte einfach
mal sehen wie war das hier ist es war
wichtig oder nordsee vor gericht vor ja
das ist die halbe karte die waren wir
komplett irgendwie maps gebaut wurden
ist cloud ronja und studieren
diese hängt suppenschüssel ist es für
die party noch nicht erkundet worden
sind weil die konzerne dranhängen wenn
es immer der kunde tatsächlich okay also
da muss jeder mit einer meterlangen oder
so ich kenne
und wie gesagt hier ist an der sonne
ach da hinten von auch welche genau das
ist alles schon voll das ist richtig
krass und hier links ist diese motto
burg dies total krass ich bin im hohen
gras dem würfel bietet nicht
wie bin ich nicht ganz leise die tun
sind gesichert werden
das habe ich hier haben das geschafft
ich denke ich bin ab
muss genau springen wenn auf die dinger
bis ich muss sie vor und dann kommst du
denn das hier perfekt vor dem stark
alter des hälfte selbst nämlich
zugesprochen weil ich selber schaut euch
dieses an mit dem shape ein heimspiel
wenn du auf den schild klicks ende
fahren heute ist man wieder eine
exotische wasserwelt dran
deswegen bringt ihr das nicht viel
da ist bürger zombie widmen
das ist nicht wirklich ein pack bleibe
wichtig noch wenn du hier mal irgendwo
weggehen sollte es ganz weit und lässt
sich in der in der farm welt kannst du
einfach nur durch kollekten und connect
ist wieder auf der normalen welt also
damit er nie merken wo du bist in der
farbwelt einfach nur disconnect dann
bist du wieder daran meinem haus minuten
nur dritter
ok und wenn ich jetzt holz möchte oder
so kann ich zeigen
da ist nämlich ua simon auch man dies
hat man aber ich werde nicht an skype
kannst du mir was soll ich da sagen es
war holz holz kann hier zeigen ich kann
dir auf essen zeigen dann also die
beiden sachen wenigstens schon mal weg
ok super danke wenn ich wahrscheinlich
demnächst auch manchmal alleine aufnehme
werde ich dann auch ein bisschen mehr
schneiden einfach damit es nicht so
monoton das aber ich dachte die erste
folge dass sie einfach so eine
ungeschnittene part ab
wir sind ganz viele felder musst du nur
wieder anbauen aber dann kannst du
kannst du die freiheit nutzen die ferien
bei allen gehören nehmen und dabei muss
halt nur wieder anpflanzen musste
einzige die einzigen bedingungen mit
benutzen zu dürfen und das holz das holz
ist noch ein bisschen weiter hinten also
da einfach wenn du da es weitergeht
solltest mitnehmen
e-mail ist voll voll weil meine familie
kommt jetzt ludger ludger das ist mein
großcousin heißt es eigentlich corsa
oder cousin der freunde schaut euch
diese kleine teilweise treten einfach so
bläschen auf das ist richtig schön wenn
ich hoffe ganz langsam zunehmen
das sieht so schön aus sie muss aber den
sonnenuntergang lauf müsse das war so
ein schönes ende manchmal der krasse
alter der bombastischen richtig
faszinierend übel
welcher baum fiel kommt lebens auf der
erde gebaut wird an der seite gelöscht
hat
du musst mal den sonnenuntergang laufen
kannst du jemand von was ihr von hier
floss drauf und dann manchmal eine art
karte
say goodbye
lassen
ich kann mich hier weiter laufen
diese folge von minecraft leben hielt es
euch gefallen hat wie ich mich neben
tief bei einem bewertungen freuen
so machte es oben in der beschreibung
verlinkt und an dem wir uns bei mehreren
folgen von